und sie sehen unseren hygiene experten
professor klaus-dieter zastrow
jetzt hast du guten abend halten sie
denn den beschluss jetzt für richtig
ausschließlich auf medizinische masken
zu setzen
ja dass das ist sehr richtig das hatten
wir auch von anfang an verlangt bloß
damals nach vier monaten hin und her in
maske ja maske nein dies ist dann
plötzlich es wäre nicht ausreichend und
genügend masken verfügbar
das ist ja nun aber vorbei und wir haben
eben mit den medizinischen masken wie
sie genannt werden die op masken haben
wir über jahrzehnte hervorragende
erfahrungen und die prüfverfahren zeigt
auch immer wieder und auch die
tatsächlich auch die infektionsraten die
wir im krankenhaus haben zeigen dass die
masken absolut gut
die viren zurückhalten können das heißt
also die tröpfchen werden zurückgehalten
die ssb zwei maske die ist ja nun gar
keine medizinische maske das auch schon
wieder eine fehlerhafte namensgebung
denn die kommt aus dem baumarkt und da
versuchen wir baustopp zurück zu halten
und nur irgend jemand auf die idee
kommen die damals als es die
chirurgische masken angeblich nicht gab
dann versuchen wir es noch mal damit
also ist ein bisschen verwirrend und die
prüftechnik unterscheidet sich doch bei
den beiden und es wird in die
einrichtung geprüft bei der op maske
nämlich nach draußen ist der patient
geschützt und bei der bau maske wird
genau andersrum geprüft und was manchmal
auch noch verwirrend ist dass du dich
überall dass die zähne user sei es
einmal produkt das hat aber was damit zu
tun dass wir bei der op maske natürlich
die maske nicht öfter verwenden können
weil er sonst eine übertragung von
infektionserregern auch die nächste den
nächsten patienten möglich wäre
natürlich können wir die auch öfter
tragen wenn wir sie nicht zerstören und
das gleiche gilt auch für die ssb zwei
maske da sagte er stella natürlich
achtung nur
einmal wenn die nämlich mit staub
verstopft ist dann kriegst du keine lust
mehr und das könnte passiert aber es
passiert hier bei uns nicht das war auch
meine nächste frage gewesen
jetzt haben sie die schon beantwortet
aber trotzdem im alltag man kennt ja
gerade im job also spätestens wenn man
essen geht setzt man diese maske ab dann
liegt die auf dem tisch da kann was weiß
ich was rankommen die verhält sich das
also muss man da jetzt genau aufpassen
auf seine maske wo man die hinlegt oder
wie kann man damit umgehen
naja es ist es wird immer so auch
erklärt also mit maske auf keinen fall
in berühren
ja das ist ja unsinn man natürlich das
sind ja meine eigenen händen meine
eigenheime und jetzt gehe ich mal davon
aus dass ich falls ich tatsächlich
corona die iren an den händen haben
sollte dann habe ich ja alle male schon
im nasen-rachen-raum im mund in der
lunge also da muss man sich gar nicht
verbiegen und darüber nachdenken was ich
jetzt mit dieser maske mache natürlich
draußen könnten wenn ich in der umgebung
von kohle erkrankten mich bewege auch
wären dann dran sein
also es ist dann klug die maske ich sage
mal so ein bisschen aufzustellen dass
man ein wenig berührung damit hat aber
und jetzt kommt der entscheidende punkt
die menge von bruna viren die auf der
maske sein könnte die ist so gering dass
sie überhaupt keine infektions dosis hat
aber natürlich fängt alles mit sehr
wenigen wären an und die werden dann
immer häufiger deswegen erzähle ich auch
immer also die ich seinen rachen alle
drei tage des implizieren dann kann
sowieso nix passieren wenn man das macht
und dann haben wir auch wieder im sommer
unseren spaß aber entscheidend ist
natürlich dass wir wissen von der maske
geht eigentlich keine gefahr aus wenn
wir ende und mund entsprechend
desinfizieren ja herr professor dann
kommen wir mal zu den kosten das ist
nämlich auch so ein ding also diese
masken da gibt's ja von einem euro bis
fast 40 euro alles auf den markt können
sie uns da ein bisschen helfen
sowas darf so eine maske kosten und wie
erkenne ich vielleicht auch fälschungen
also die chirurgische masken wie die
medizinischen massen die kosten für die
krankenhäuser die im großen stil
einkaufen die damals locker 100.000
stück kaufen
die kaufen die zurzeit so ungefähr für
15 16 17 cent ein
wenn man es in der apotheke kaufen heißt
ja nicht umsonst apotheker preise also
besonders hoch gut da ist dann noch eine
entspannende es entsprechende spannung
drin der apotheker will auch noch was
verdienen aber mehr als 40 50 cent darf
so eine maske nicht kosten dann ist das
buch ja also unter ausnutzung einer
notlage und die nach sp2 maske die
werden gekauft im moment in den
krankenhäusern so zwischen 1 euro und 1
euro 50
wenn dann in der apotheke sagen wir mal
drei euro genommen werden dann ist das
gerade noch okay aber mehr sollte es
auch nicht sein das wäre dann wieder
jura preis und einzig aber gleich noch
sagen man kann sie eben mehrfach
benutzen
herr professor zastrow danke für ihre
klaren worte ich glaube da haben sie
fielen wieder geholfen einen schönen
abend an sie
danke danke mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bate schau dich
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren